[Music]
so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
of tomorrow's front pages it's time to
see what's making the headlines with
daily mail economist susie boniface
who's joined by the uh columnist at the
article ali mirage and they'll be with
us from now until just before midnight
so let's check out some of those front
pages for you starting with the daily
telegraph giving in to strikers will
lead to more walkouts and higher
inflation that's the view of the
treasury in the telegraph the ft weekend
reports that global stocks have suffered
one of their worst weeks since the
beginning of the coronavirus pandemic
onto the daily mirror which says that
support mccartney has axed the beatles
song back in the ussr from his live
shows as a protest against the war in
ukraine
the guardian leads with schools pools
and libraries facing massive cuts
because of local authority funding
shortages
here's your times saying that bosses are
being warned against giving employees
big wage increases
the daily express reports airport
workers have been told to work longer
hours to save the nation's summer
and the eye leads with a poll showing
people want boris johnson to do more to
fix the economy
and don't forget by scanning the qr code
you can see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and as i say i'm joined
tonight by susie boniface and ali
maharaj how are you both you are you
sweltering or you keep it are you
keeping cool susie
yeah i've got my own little uh little
wind machine here i feel like beyonce is
amazing
[Laughter]
what about you ali have you got a little
fan in there
i i'm afraid i don't but let's see how i
feel in the next hour and a half all
right we'll see if you've got a hanky to
it to mop your brow um i'll tell you
what ally why don't you uh uh kick
things off for us looking at this uh
story on the front of the times
big wage increases are simply too risky
uh bosses are being told as we try and
sort out this
uh inflation running away from us
that's right this is simon clark being
reported in the times of chief secretary
of the treasury uh really calling for
wage restraint worrying that we're going
to get into this a wage price
inflationary spiral this is something
that the governor of the bank of england
andrew bailey
talked about a couple of months ago was
ridiculed roundly for being insensitive
and out of touch uh for suggesting
exactly this
the problem we've got jonathan is that
as was revealed by the monetary policy
committee uh just yesterday when he
raised rates
um to 0.75
sorry about by um
by another 0.25 percent
um rates are going up they're 1.25
percent now the fed tightened even
further than the bank of england did by
0.75 and we need to get a grip on
inflation i mean we're going to see
interest rates going up now
unfortunately this comes at a time when
um people are suffering around the
country with
energy prices rising cost of living
issues
but we need to be we need to understand
that there is not a crisis for 27
million households in this country there
is a crisis of 5 to 10 million
households and those should be helped
and indeed the chancellor did help them
by this extra 21 billion that was
announced in the last um a couple of
weeks that's absolutely right i
personally wouldn't have given the 400
pounds uh additional grant to everyone
in the country because i don't think it
was needed the rest of us are going to
have to cut our coat according to our
cloth we're going to have to take some
pain because we've got a 400 billion
overhang from covid and in a rising
interest rate environment the chancellor
does not want to have
additional debt servicing on 2 trillion
of public debt so that's where we are
susie
uh yes we so we do have the situation
where we have
uh massive price rises partly due to
covered parties to brexit probably to
ukraine and if we all got paid more
money
to cater for that then prices don't come
down again
and that prices actually keep going up
because people are prepared to pay them
the only way you bring prices down is if
people are not able to make those
uh they're not able to pay it
and then eventually being sort of bottom
out a bit but to get to that point
people have to go through pain as ali
said and that means people who are
middle class and doing okay are gonna do
significantly worse and it means people
who are at the bottom and really
struggling are going to really hit the
bottom and some people aren't going to
be able to get through it in one piece
and so the problem is here we have this
the public urge for more money in our
pockets please because things are tight
it's difficult
um
combined with the fact that the
government who is looking that is
looking a bit longer term is saying well
you actually have to have a crunch here
you have to have a correction and this
is a problem but combined with all that
it's not just the fact that one or two
people are asking for a bit more money
or um as they're saying here in the
article that you know that um that some
uh union discussions i think there's the
telegraph they're writing about some
union discussions are actually going to
give rises of absolute 20 for some
people because there are so many who
have been on low wages for such a long
time or in the gig economy that actually
wages coming up is the correction as
well
and so we've got this kind of
post-pandemic economic
contraction crunch change going on it
happened after the black death as well
it happened after spanish flew um
economists do have this
terrible situation after you have a big
health problem like the pandemic and so
we are going to have to go through this
process and the trouble is when you do
that you really need people running the
country running the economy who know
exactly what they're doing um it doesn't
help when they are earning six figures
and are telling us to to pull our belts
tighten our belts and pull our necks in
a bit that's not good look whether it's
the bank of england or uh people who
work for the government but
you need to have people you can trust
and rely on to get you through this and
to think that they know the bigger
picture and therefore whatever we're
suffering there's a point to it and i
think the viewers just need to question
whether they feel that's the government
they've got okay which leads us on to uh
the front page of the eye ally
the public tell johnson act now to help
the uk economy uh there's a poll that's
been done which uh suggests two-thirds
of voters say the government isn't doing
enough to tackle the cost of living
crisis it says a large majority of the
public wants more decisive action on the
economy
the public have got to get real i mean
i'm a member of the public too we're all
suffering over this i mean it's going to
be paying all round to varying degrees
the poorest in society need to be helped
the most that is where we need to
channel
our support and they should be helped
and they already have been helped and
i'm sure that uh when the price cap off
generally to the price cap on energy
costs in october
some more help may be forthcoming
but honestly we have to get real people
talk about crises that word is inflated
there's a crisis going on in ukraine in
several don x when people are having
their heads blown off and their homes
raised to the ground there's a crisis
going on in sri lanka where people can't
get food and they're queuing up for
hours this isn't that economic crisis
though isn't it this is an economic
crisis
it is
i agree but it's not for everyone and by
the way jonathan when everyone's having
a heart attack about 1.25 interest rates
interest rates in the late uh 90s were
7.5 they were 5.7
in in 2007. let's put this in context
yes it's tough for people out there they
should be helped the bottom end who are
really struggling the rest of us are
going to have to cut our discretionary
spending how we get i think people have
forgotten that we've just spent um the
best part of 400 billion on kovid i mean
paying people's wages for for for two
years in some cases on furlough was
gonna have a massive economic impact
where do we think this money comes from
the government only raises money by
taxing you or by borrowing there is a
third way and it's called printing money
quantitative easing which leads to
inflation that's why we've got this
problem to a degree so that i'm sorry
there is no easy answer and i think the
government is now being honest finally
with people michael gove said it rishi
sunax having restraint is not going to
go for tax cuts now we've just got to
accept that this is going to be a really
difficult period susie give me your
reaction to that and then i'm going to
ask you quickly about the story on the
front of the guardian
um
the fact that the government i think
talk about tax cuts and conflating with
the inflationary issues we've got
two completely different things the
inflation we've got and how we deal with
that there's global problems that are
going on it is affecting some other
countries far differently to us we're
having the luxury of being able to vote
like this but tax cuts or austerity
measures are not related so if anybody
comes along says we need to cut services
to repay this it's tribe
the money that was spent on covid and
the money that may be spent on any of
these issues is money that literally the
government can tell the bank of england
we want some money and then the
government can later tell the bank of
england you need to forget that we owe
you that money the money doesn't it's
gone you don't you don't owe you
anything more you just literally the
government and the bank of england
rewrite their current account to fit so
it's not a case that we borrow from
ourselves in order to and we have to pay
it back to ourselves that's just not the
case okay and just 30 seconds susie on
the front of the guardian then
on that on that theme the guardian has
uh suggested there's a 1.7 billion hole
in uh budgets for things like schools
swimming pools libraries as well
yeah so this is the real cost of when
you have inflation problems everyone
who's budgeted whether it's a household
budget or a local authority for their
spending for the upcoming year um
they suddenly find that the costs of the
things they have to do have gone through
the roof and so that's where real cuts
do start coming in and it's your local
government which affects far more of
your daily life than the national
government we like to talk about that's
your social care that's your dustbins
that's your schools and that's where the
cuts are really going to buy and that's
starting already okay ali we'll get your
thoughts on that uh after 11 o'clock
we're going to have to go to a break uh
coming up in a couple of minutes this
story it's on the front of the express
saying that airport workers have been
told to work longer hours to save the
nation's summer don't go away
[Music]
[Music]
part two of the press preview susie and
ali still with me uh ali tell us about
this story on the front of the daily
telegraph the home secretary has given a
wide-ranging interview hasn't she to the
paper uh including calling the european
convention on human rights scandalous
over its decision to ground that first
rwandan deportation flight
well look the policy was on the back of
trying to deal with an issue that is
pervasive we've had 30 000 people across
the channel illegally last year 10 000
so far this year the government has to
be seen to be getting a grip of this and
controlling the borders and basically
everything it's tried so far including
dealing with the french on extensive
negotiations and discussions including
50 million quid that was given to them
has failed so had something had to be
done 130 people were meant to go on this
flight it ended up with seven meant to
be going and then in the end it was
challenged by by european judges under
the convention on human rights um rule
39 the right to a family life and the
others cited the same case and the thing
didn't take off and 300 000 pounds uh
this slide was gonna cost potentially
wasted
the thing is patel is saying she's good
she wants us to pull out of the european
convention on human rights replacing a
bill of rights to take control of who we
decide is going to stay in this country
and not allow people smugglers who
unscrupulously allow people to come
along and pay them seven thousand pounds
a pop and put their lives at risk to
abuse an asylum system and i think it's
absolutely fair that certain action is
taken here something had to be done
susie says ali
about up to 85 of the people who come
across using people traffickers in that
way across the channel are genuine
asylum seekers so something didn't have
to be done uh what needed to be done was
to stop the people traffickers
uh having that access to people and
being able to exploit them the best way
of doing that is either to set up proper
authorized reception centers elsewhere
there are many many countries in the
world where there is not possible to
have a legal route to get into the uk
there are no ways to get a visa in
places like for example eritrea
um so it's it needs to be sorted out a
lot of those who are appearing in the
camps in calais now are from afghanistan
there was a report earlier on of someone
who was trying to get to the uk because
this is where his wife is now under
normal asylum rules you have an absolute
right to join a spouse if they're in
another country and they've been given
asylum um but for some reason that chap
has been either denied entry or is but
not had his application processed
properly or he's not even been able to
apply i don't know quite the background
there but if he's got a spouse in this
country he's a slam dunk
for a genuine asylum plane as soon as
he's come from afghanistan uh he's
probably our responsibility anyway
morally um but he's stuck there in a
camp in calais paying people traffickers
because of the way we have had this
hostile environment for our asylum
system if we just made it a sane
environment then perhaps we'd be able to
assess people properly and do it in a
better more authorized way okay we'll
talk more about that i know you want to
come back ali but we're out of time
we'll talk more about it after 11
o'clock just tell me very quickly about
this story on the front of the telegraph
kate bush you're a kate bush fan ali
she's had a number one single
um
with a song that's 37 years old
well she is the first uh uk female solo
artist who had a
number one uh top of the album chart
she's an iconic figure uh very haunting
songs i mean look personally i prefer
uh the dance remix of cloud boston that
came out not so long ago which i drop
into my dj sets rather than running up
that hill but it's you know it's a
classic it's an iconic track and i think
it's very good that younger
people are introduced to this music and
can connect with it i think it's very
good i think the only issue here is
protecting new talent and new artists as
well and that's why i think the way
these uh these way these streams are
counted uh makes a lot of sense to me
but i think it's great that we're
connecting the younger people are
connecting with kate bush susie very
briefly
i've never managed to get on with
stranger things but all i can remember
kate bush is that that song was also
used for a fantastic tv program in 1986
called running scared which people of my
age might remember um and we all cared
about kate bush in 1986 um and of course
that was a bit more recent and more
nearly the time that she actually did
release the track but uh in those days
of course she wasn't able to access
millions and millions and millions and
millions of people to push it to the top
of an album chart those days at the top
of the album shot you get a few hundred
thousand and you were yeah you were
number one yeah now it's down to
streaming and it's so many more i reckon
if you brought that little fan a bit
closer to your uh face um susie can we
do quite a good impression of kate bush
in one of our videos thank you both very
much indeed perfect look at that perfect